when we first got together I was like
the entrepreneur and I had five gyms at
the time Lea was a personal trainer and
I was like come join to my thing we're
going to do this all this stuff together
and she was always talking about team
and people and I was like right anyways
so Marketing sales offer pricing the
stuff that like tends to be more my
wheelhouse the hard Sciences of business
I had only been able to make like2 or $3
million a year as like my personal cap
as an entrepreneur it was only once Lela
came in that everything kind of blew up
after that and so first it was sure
people but the hard stuff and then it
was okay there's culture and there's
strategy and they're equally important
and I would say now we just see them as
culture is strategy build people and the
people build the company